Sarah Chen: Good morning everyone. Let's keep it quick today — I know we've got a lot going on. Marcus, kick us off.
Marcus Johnson: Morning. So yesterday I finally got the ClickHouse schema locked in for issue #68 — closed that out. The partitioning by service and date is going to make our aggregation queries way faster. Today I'm starting on the latency query API, that's issue #69. Should have a draft endpoint up by EOD.
Sarah Chen: Nice. And quick heads up on a decision — Marcus and I synced with the data team yesterday and we're going with ClickHouse over TimescaleDB for the metrics backend. Benchmarks showed 3-4x better performance on the aggregation queries. That's final. Priya, you're up.
Priya Patel: Yeah so the notification tray component, issue #63, is coming along but I'm running into a tricky issue with real-time badge count updates. Right now we're polling the REST endpoint which means there's a lag. I need to hook into the WebSocket event stream but that depends on Marcus's fanout work in #62. So slight blocker there, but not urgent yet.
Marcus Johnson: Yeah, let's pair on that tomorrow afternoon. The fanout worker is mostly done — I'm just cleaning up the error handling. One thing: we agreed to drop priority queuing from this sprint. All notification types get treated equally for now. Keeps things simpler and we can add priority tiers in a follow-up launch.
Priya Patel: That's fine by me, honestly. Also, the alert threshold UI for issue #71 is done and shipped — QA signed off. Feels good to close one.
David Kim: QA side — I've started smoke testing the notification event schema that got closed yesterday, issue #61. Everything looks consistent with the CloudEvents spec. I do want to add some edge case tests around the custom extension field. Should have a report by end of day. No blockers.
Alex Rivera: Quick thing from me — the staging Kafka cluster had a blip this morning, about 15 minutes of downtime. It's back up. I'm adding a health check alert so we catch that faster next time. For today I'm picking up the dashboard frontend work on issue #67, getting the time-series chart component wired up with the new metrics API once Marcus has that endpoint ready.
Sarah Chen: Great. Let's keep an eye on that Kafka reliability — if it's flaky in staging it'll be a problem in Beta. David, can you log that as a risk? Alright, that's everyone. Have a good one.
[Multiple voices]: Thanks, bye!